is the first day after our horses came
home we're gonna shoot a morning routine
we don't even know what our routine is
yet
but Sophie and I are gonna do it you
have to listen to me yeah because I have
stuff planned out do you have stuff
Linda we feed them I put honey in our
stalls to eat and then I put Willow
Chino and let me bring storm out and
then we put honey back up okay I did not
catch any of that okay so you guys know
Sam and Sophie usually do morning chores
I told Sam stay in bed sleep in as long
as you want and Sophia and I will do
chores today because it's only three
steps from our house
and because I'm excited to see our
horses so let's go see them I think
that's the same thing
so if you watched our nighttime routine
then this is just basically that but in
reverse
we left all the doors open last night so
it'll be nice and cool in here
today's job I have so many plans for
today
[Laughter]
all right we're gonna let Sophie lead
because she knows what to do
she knows like but they're kind of
visiting
so Penny doesn't love any other horse
ever if she's gonna love if there's any
horse in this world that she loves
it's him and I'm praying for a day
they're back together again
here give me storms
wear storms
oh
wow Chino you ate all that hay and you
pooed he's just staring at his girl he's
like I don't care about food
Penny's like I don't care about my food
while she cares about her food I want to
see how he did in this stall
did you like it storm
he
didn't eat much of his hay pooped in it
drink some water lay down I see some
some shavings in his tail we'll get him
more savings today
how was it
Chino eat your food man
so like I said this is going to be open
up eventually we're just gonna like
increase the horse's time on grass
slowly because
I don't want them to go from like 12
hours to 24 hours just like that
yeah you're
just let her stand right out here I can
even close this door
oh if she'll go to our food
yeah
that's your food we'll put stalls we'll
put mats in there today we have a lot to
do still
oh yeah she can't get out from here what
the heck and if she gets out she'll just
be in her normal field yeah like even if
you did open that while
I don't know oh yeah I guess because
they're not going to run out and leave
their food watch honey yeah
honey what are you doing
honey is such a Honey hi handsome you
settle down
so we are watching them on the cameras
last night everybody seemed happy
everybody seemed fine
we try to keep our routine exactly the
same as we did at the old place
I love those doors
oh my gosh they're stunning
oh
what's happening wait a minute
this is not you get back in there and
eat your food get back in there
I have to close her in
oh storm
no get your face away from her butt that
my friends is why they put bars on the
doors
she let Willow out Willow goes with
Chino now
she's coming
we know you don't want to be alone oh
you could probably go out see if I had a
hook here and I had your uh
your rope I could probably lead you out
so being able to do this I'm just going
to use pennies
um like being able to come out here and
see what we need
is gonna help so we definitely need our
a hook on Storm's door
so if you can't catch Willow now
storm no we're not going that way
this is the house of many gates you'll
get you'll get used to it should I let
storm out
or not yet
okay because he doesn't isn't in a field
with with
Willow so it won't go bad it won't go
well
storm came right into this farm and put
his butt up against that wood wall and
just started scratching
wait storm we gotta wait for Sophie
so your plan did not go to plan
our brains are still sleeping it's 7 A.M
or Willow she just wants to be with her
girls and they will be so I've been
explaining this to people but this is
going to be their winter field so once
rainy season happens in just a couple of
weeks
and just
so excited poor thing so once rainy
season happens
um the horses will trample this to death
especially right here and there will
probably be like a little bit of grass
down there
she's still there
uh oh I lost honey oh crap don't ever
leave me in charge
even though he tries to herd
Gracie she's his best friend and you
know what's weird they have the same
personality oh so she just went out into
that little area out there
come on
you can go for grass now little mini
[Music]
push Penny around
they're both leaders in their own way
she's she's like a standoffish leave me
alone leader and he's uh
I'm the boss of you
it's kind of oh Penny must be coming
into heat because this doesn't ever
happen
Penny does not get close to
horses and storm always leaves her alone
so something's going on
[Music]
you're crazy for saying interesting
story people have been suggesting that
we use this room for a wash doll and the
flooring like when this stuff gets wet
it's a nuisance it gets stuck on
everything it is
annoying but then someone today said put
mats out here and I was thinking oh my
gosh I don't know how that would be for
winter like in snow and and stuff no I
love the idea so we can put cross rails
out here or we could put cross ties out
here
we could
literally make this into the coolest
washed all ever it would be in out of
the Sun the hoses here we could put a
shelf up there and put all of our
shampoos and all of our stuff out there
for summer like this could be our summer
on our horses I think would love it
anyway it's definitely something that I
think we can do I need to get all this
stuff out of here and that's going to be
a job that I am working on I absolutely
am working on this like
I haven't been for the few last few days
but I'm gonna get it all out all right
so our morning routine also consists of
cleaning up the bar and cleaning up the
Stalls there's a lot of poop everywhere
getting grain ready for tonight throwing
hay for these two
um but I'm not going to show all that
because you guys know what that looks
like because we have more morning chores
to do horses are not our only chore in
the morning so we're gonna do all those
things and then we're going to show you
our next step I do want to say that even
though the horses are home this Barn is
Not By Any Means finished we have like I
want to put up some stands or some
shelving and some hooks so that
everything is Within Reach like Sophie
has her bag over there and it works out
perfect there holy heck it is hot today
you guys anyway I want to do all I want
to get it all set up so that it looks
like a barn
step two in morning chores is letting
our goats out but apparently they got
out in the night regardless Sophie did
it up
five these Vines will trip you
so clearly they don't need to be locked
up at night they were watching us with
the horses they're like oh I see you
there Ellie be careful
yeah Ellie Don't Go Near them Ellie
tried to leave her in the house she is
so tiny she can sneak right out
like we have a whole routine of how we
keep Ellie in the house when we don't
want her out here
she's right staying right with me though
okay
she didn't get trampled she got charged
these are your dogs actually because of
Miss Tilly Tilly and Rosie Tilly and
Rosie
so I don't
know how they got out but they got out
hopefully the cat didn't
come on Ellie Center the fence at least
Ellie's gone
hopefully go look and make sure
because they seem very suspiciously
interested
I abandoned Ellie
boy
so see how good he is he like runs free
in the barn all day all night and then
during the day when we have the doors
open we leave them in here we make sure
he has lots of food lots of water and
every time we come down to uh do the
goats which is often
um I come down here like 30 times a day
yeah we come down here like 30 times a
day but when we do come down we come and
we visit him we spend time with him we
give him treats today's not my day
today's not my day either I'm grumpy
sorry Sophie
so we come and we visit Ollie and we
make sure he has lots of food and water
and
he's got good he's all good
yeah it's lots of scratches he's
shedding we should get a brush and brush
him he probably really love it
everybody like any was never like that
before so what I wanted to say is that
we moved him from the other Barn where
the dogs are always running in and out
to down here and he is obsessed he loves
this Barn he's so much more confident he
runs free all night long stays in here
during the day I might have to get a fan
today it's hot but this Barn is way way
cooler than the other Barn
so much happier down here too so much
happier
and like someone said
um he'll take care of like all the
rodents and stuff down in this barn and
then Ellie will take care of them from
another barn oh goodness did you tie
this in a knot what the heck did you do
it well you're gonna have to go out
there and get that open
because I do not know what you did grab
the scissors there's no scissors in this
Barn we are going to make like a first
aid kit for this Barn
or a kit of things we need we're gonna
get things to hang up down here we have
a lot of stuff that we have to do
not work
to be honest I think leaving them out
leaving that door open all night is
probably a million times better than
them trying to get through the door and
hurting themselves
do you want me to do it
it's not my good day it's not my good
day either
I don't know if you guys can see Ellie
watch on the other side of the gate
Ellie is afraid of nothing
the goats
we give them they even run for me
anymore yeah we give them little bits of
grain to bring them close to us to make
them friendly
she's like I know that when I'm held I
get grained
hi
I think you miss him
so cute we're really careful about how
much cream we give the boy
he he's the heaviest like he
he's gonna be neutered soon he's gonna
get fixed really really soon
Ellie's out there she came through she's
like I need to get to my mom I try not
to bring Ellie down here because the
goats think that she's put her on this
side of the gate although the door's
open you're okay might I add that all
these chores are done before we even
have breakfast before we're even awake
yesterday I noticed that penny is
definitely unsettled here she doesn't
understand fully like what's happening
and she's nervous and she if she hears
me outside she always puts her body
somewhere where she's close and she can
see me so she often hangs out in this
field
or like no matter where I am if I look
out she's close to me last on the list
we haven't even done like actual chores
yet like clean I need to go have a drink
first because it's hot
it's only going to be hot later hotter
later though there are a lot of things
that we still have to finish on our on
this area we're still making uh
room for our
duck and
Goose
but everybody wants it out in the
morning there you go
everybody's got water
any eggs
everybody's got food
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hi Zoey
you know
come here come here
come here dude who was that all right so
she's gonna take them to their area I
use this trash can and the shovel and I
just scoop out their shavings during the
night before they're hay they're bedding
from the night before and then I dump it
and it's so easy these guys need water
cleaning out the deck and the goose is
so easy I literally scoop it three
scoops and it's out and then I dump it I
am going to get them fresh water clean
their water buckets
for tonight
also get
baby chicken water also on the agenda
today we're going to clean the the duck
pond the little pool I know that it can
get dirtier than that and be okay for
decks but I like it to be clean I was
paranoid I was checking out all nights
on the camera look
and he's lying down oh I wonder
they love it Willow's in the corner and
Gracie's there that looks like honey oh
is that on any problems
can you get a picture of that and save
it for me
oh is it picture
she's not laying down right now I know
but I wanted to see them like that's the
only reason we kept that awful dirt in
there is because it was a
that's at 4 30 in the morning yeah I
knew that they would love it like I have
tick tocks coming out soon where our
horses are rolling in that dirt anyway
lots to do more to see stick around
subscribe before more Barn Renovations
because there's a lot of barn
Renovations coming up on our Channel
we're gonna make our tack room and that
Barn so user friendly and so horse
friendly that you will be shocked
uh how much we've how much we've learned
and how far we've come from the people
who never had horses before and now
we're setting up our barn
so that our horses are the most
comfortable they can be
[Music]